so today i want to review what some have
deemed my hottest takes when it comes to
dating advice or maybe my worst takes
they're kind of it's it's all
perspective one or the other i've done a
few installments of giving such advice
to the sad souls who use reddit so now i
think it's time to reflect on the
important knowledge
i've shared with these sad souls now i
of course objectively write in all these
cases but it doesn't stop everybody from
disagreeing with what i have to say
let's take a look this one says wife
might have lost interest in me and be
looking elsewhere
we've been together for five years now
for the last six months we've been
fighting and arguing a lot it's mostly
stopped over the last two to three weeks
but as of this last weekend she
suggested an open relationship
stating that she's read that men are
happier i do not want it but the more i
think about it the more i feel like she
wants it for her
she's always getting hit on even when
i'm right there and i work long hours so
i'm not home a lot i know if i agree to
this it would be just for her
i don't want anyone else and even if i
did i'm unattractive and socially
awkward so it's not like i'd get
anywhere
what set me over the edge is that i gave
her my card before work to pay rent got
home and wanted a soda for the store and
as i was looking for it in her purse i
found a letter she wrote today
it doesn't say who it's sue but it's
obviously not for me and it's signed
love always
and then her name i don't know what to
do at this point do i tell her how i've
been feeling
do i confront her about the letter my
god these are depressing
i think i might cry
if i had a soul i would cry
but i don't so we're good but anyway
do you
do do you confront her what do you mean
yes
what else would you do this could very
well be the stupidest person on the face
of the earth what do you mean do you
what other i mean she literally wrote a
love letter to another guy
how could you not confront her what el
would you what else what's the other
option would you go home
like order a pizza watch masterchef
together pretend everything's fine
is that even a feasible option
if i was in your shoes i couldn't do
that that would be impossible to do that
you can't be so cowed so emasculated
that you've that you that you're
that good at hiding your thoughts and
feelings around her so yes you confront
her yes you put your foot down none of
this is okay none of it is remotely okay
and by the way there's no such thing as
an open marriage not quite my tempo a
marriage by definition is closed
there's no open marriage
it's like saying that you live in a
house without a roof if it doesn't have
a roof it's not a house
the roof is like sort of the whole point
of the house that's what we talk about
you know you're living under my roof i
need a roof just it's the roof that's
the the roof is one of the is one of the
main features of the house and if you
don't have that you don't have a house
um and in a marriage
the one of the primary defining features
is the exclusive exclusivity is the
commitment you make to anot to one
another
so there's no open marriage what there
is is uh it's called adultery cheating
and even if you both agree to it it's
still adultery all right next
it says i feel like i'm not allowed to
have my own time i've been dating my
girlfriend for almost half a year now
and it's been mostly great other than
her clinginess she's the type to send
multiple walls of text while i'm at work
and then when i give her a quick
response trying to explain to her i'm
busy she thinks i'm upset at her which
in reality i am and i've tried to
explain to her that there's no need to
blow my phone up when i'm on the clock
at work or at school i'm trying to
explain to her i'm busy and i've even
set boundaries for her to not borderline
spam me when i don't reply but i feel
like when i bring this up she thinks you
don't want me to text you at all she's
also tried calling me while i'm at work
and uh when i don't answer she'll text
my parents asking if i'm safe
there's also been instances of me having
to text her to get her to let me be when
i'm hanging out with a friend
okay i think we get the idea here
extremely clingy extremely needy once
again i would say break up bafflation uh
now granted
you guys have been dating for half a
year you'd say which uh which means
you've barely been together at all okay
so you're you're still babies in a
relationship and she's still in the
infatuation stage of things and every
couple has the infatuation stage when
you're sort of obsessed with each other
and you need to be around each other 24
7
which there's no love before the
infatuation
is gets in the way of love there can't
be real love because
the infatuation state stage is
self-focused you're obsessed with how
this person makes you feel
so it's all about you she's texting and
calling you all the time not because
she's actually worried about you but
more that she needs that constant
connection with you for her own self she
doesn't really care if she's intruding
on you or not so it's really not about
you at all it's more about her
tell me i'm pretty tell me i'm pretty
there's probably nothing beneath the
infatuation except the infatuation
itself this would be one of those
situations where you stay with her
and then in a few months she gets bored
and just breaks up with you all she'll
go from
utterly obsessed with you she too she
doesn't want any anything to do with you
just like that or she'll cheat or
something so i just cut this one off now
i mean general rule here
if you've been dating for only six
months
and she's already annoying the hell out
of you every second of the day
not a good sign so i would uh
just leave that one alone let me ask you
something what if there was somebody out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day i
think it would be pretty creepy well
what if i told you that's exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider like 18 to your
comcast is allowed to store logs of
every website you've ever visited and
can legally sell this data to anybody
they want that's why i always use
expressvpn especially again reroute your
internet connection through their secure
server so your internet provider cannot
see or log whatever you do online many
of you might be wondering well if i'm
routing all my data through a vpn then
doesn't that just mean the vpn can see
what i'm doing and log my data instead
and you're right to think about that
many vpns claim to have a no logs policy
but they've been caught logging customer
activity anyway expressvpn though is the
only vpn i trust because they use
trusted server technology they were the
first major vpn provider to engineer all
of their vpn servers to run in ram and
this makes it rather impossible for
their vpn servers to store any data
including logs of any expressvpn
customers they're not giving any of that
information at all you don't have to
take my or expressvpn's word for it
expressvpn is so confident in their no
logs claim they've even had one of the
biggest insurance firms pwc audit their
technology
stop letting people keep logs of what
you do online visit expressvpn.com
walsh yt right now and find out how you
can get three months free okay next
question
so i've been on three dates with this
girl and we're really clicking and i
really like her and she just agreed to a
fourth date tomorrow and it's been about
less than two weeks since we started
talking point is every now and then she
goes off for a good few hours and i
don't know i'm in all sorts of stress
i don't want to say anything to her
about it because i don't want to
overwhelm or seem needy but i need to be
able to healthily deal with this and i
just instantly run through scenarios
that she's not into me or so and so
are some people just not into texting i
don't know do i just need to chill the f
out
listen
there's nothing more repulsive to a
woman than neediness in a man that is
the most repulsive trait is to be needy
so you you are being repulsive in the
eyes of this woman
but the problem is that phones and text
messaging and all of that stuff just
ignites this kind of neediness in people
so i'm not really blaming you for this
and and like everyone is is like this to
a certain extent at this point
not just in relationships the very fact
that the other person has their phone on
them at all times means that you feel
like and not just you but universally
you feel like you're entitled to their
attention all the time
because they have on them the means by
which you can get their attention right
but you aren't
i mean you can't just barge in on
someone at all hours of the day
relentlessly whenever you feel like it
and expect that they'll drop everything
they're doing and respond to you it's
insane
but it's an insanity that you're you're
a good company because like most of the
country this is how they operate if they
send a text message they expect an
immediate response you know i frequently
get text messages and i don't respond to
them for days
i treat text messages like like their
letters
and i'm living on the
frontier in in 1835
and the male comes by horseback every
four months
i give myself that kind of time
to respond to a text message that's what
i do you know why
because i don't owe you a response
i don't owe you my attention
i'm doing something i'm in the middle of
something leave me alone or maybe i'm in
the middle of nothing
maybe i'm literally just sitting on a
chair staring at a wall
and you send me a text message you know
what i'm still gonna do i'm gonna look
at my phone and just put it down and not
respond
because i don't feel like talking right
now if i felt like talking i'd be
texting you
you see
look the point is this girl doesn't
exist simply to respond to you
if you want that go ask for a date from
siri okay see if alexa is still single
you want a human being then let them
live a life
apart from your constant surveillance
get a grip well i mean looking back on
these clips i'm not sure how anybody
could disagree with me on this or
anything else now if you want to make
your case against my advice feel free to
do so in the comments below but just
know you may be banned from the show for
doing so so be careful
you